je vais aller retrouver notre artiste
éclectique
alain biais salut alain bonjour je peux
m'asseoir un peu surtout fait on essaie
tout ajustement en plein milieu de son
expo alors des brosses à dents il ya des
tubes de dentifrice et des bouteilles de
shampoing
qu'est ce que c'est la thématique de la
saison ses figures voilà donc les
premiers les premiers objets donc j'ai
pensé c'est des objets qui touche au
corps dont les objets qui touche au
corps ya effectivement des rasoirs des
peignes et brosses à dents des casques
gants et puis tous les produits qui sont
un peu nos relations aussi des
shampoings les parfums toutes sortes de
choses qui sont appelés à toucher le
corps et donc du coup elles définirent
oscille quoi ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que tu t'es lancé dans une grande
entreprise qui n'aura jamais de fin a
priori puisque tu recense tous les
objets de notre quotidien
qu'est ce qui t'inspire dans le
quotidien way juste avant j'allais faire
un travail sur les jouets des enfants
qui l'a fait petit canon j'ai recensé
tous les jouets des enfants j'ai fait un
film
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de faire des
choses tous les jours au bout d'un
moment d'en avoir une somme assez énorme
qui me dépasse un peu en fait dont
j'oublie trouve une forme un film une
exposition en tout cas je suis amené à
les classer à trouver des exceptions etc
on voit aussi que il ya une poésie qui
est caché dans ses objets du quotidien
qui finissent souvent à poubelles ces
emballages ça fait un peu penser aussi à
un andy warhol avec ses boîtes de
concentré de tomate
quand on pense aux objets dans le dos
l'histoire de la la première mouvement
auquel on pense effectivement c'est le
pop art mais moi je ne le sens plus
proche par exemple les gens au 19e
siècle qui faisait les classements
autour d'eux des animaux et végétaux
j'aimerais qu'on voit un peu de ta
technique parce que tous tes dessins
sont allés celle ci travaille avec quoi
alors tu vois là c'est simple donc j'ai
l'objet hop je le pose je fais le tour
voilà donc donc forcément il à l'échelle
va ça me donne de gabarit ça me donne un
repère et quand je parlais des artistes
du 19e c'est la technique qui
l'utilisaient eux qui s'appelle le
dessin documentaire il s'appelle aussi
dessin objectif moi l'idée c'est de tous
ces objets c'est d'essayer de faire des
petits bijoux même quand c'est des trucs
en plastique merdique voilà c est donc
pour toi y'a pas d'objets insignifiant
quand j'ai un objet qui me plaît pas
parce qu'il ya un garde à la zone b qui
sont moche quoi rien le plein et l'idée
c'est d'essayer d'en faire un beau
dessin quoi même quand c'est pas un bel
objet y en a dans cette salle certains
auquel je pensais j'essaie de faire des
beaux dessins d'objets qui sont pas
terribles auxquelles très grand non je
ne pense pas ils nous entendent pas
c'est bon tu sais que dans cette
émission on aime bien donner des défis
aux artistes alors est ce que tu vas
accepté de relever le défi de travailler
autour de la thématique de la peau du
cuir puisqu'on a ici dans des anciennes
tanneries jeu presque toujours à
thématique là avec figurer avec
similitudes
ces objets autour du corps et du coup
sur la peau bon ben voilà il ya eric de
gouttes qui m'a donné son rasoir design
est donc ce réseau là il a le potentiel
mesdames et messieurs à devenir une
oeuvre d'art c'est la main d'allah je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas voilà c'est le
dessin et est déjà à légèrement commencé
mais on a des billets encore beaucoup de
travail c'est pas fini moi j'étais s'est
concentré alors si tu peux
bon alors vous vous souvenez tout à
l'heure on a laissé notre artiste alain
be en plein travail j'espère qu'il aura
eu le temps de relever notre défi
alors alain je relève les copines
attention ok je l' ai vu je les ai vus
elle est belle taton desalle est
incroyable donc on l'a on est sur du
dessin extrêmement réaliste il ya quand
même de toi dedans
j'espère comme tu me le disait on sent
sa patte sur tout a réussi à relever le
défi
le temps imparti n'était pas trop serré
parce que c'est quand même on voit que
dans les détails c'est extrêmement
travaillée de l'habitude je fais jamais
un dessin d'un seul coup comme ça donc
pour nous tu as fait une entorse
disons que les faits datent d'une traite
alors qu'habituellement j'ai fait j'ai
toujours plusieurs trucs en route quoi
alors qu'est-ce qu'on en fait on a le
droit d'aller la crau génial
eh ben ça va peut-être te paraître idiot
est l'un des trois sera extrêmement
émouvant d'afficher une oeuvre est de
savoir que les gens vont pouvoir venir
l'admirer et que nous on l'a vu se faire
et que nous renversons n'est peut-être
un peu aussi responsable de la naissance
de cette oeuvre
dams et messieurs le 6500 et unième
objets recensés par alain biais et il
est né sous nos yeux c'est quand même la
classe c merci hein
dorian oui tu as bien travaillé donc je
te propose une petite récompense qu est
ce que ça te dirait d'aller voir un
concert
et ben pourquoi pas allons-y vous allez
voir c'est par ces partis eux